anxiety is not a light switch on and off
it's a dimmer switch and on that
spectrum yes there's panic
yes there's overwhelming anxiety but on
the other end of the spectrum there's
this trees on of this kind of excitement
this wait i'm kind of in it to win it i
care about this thing
why does anxiety exist it's the new sort
of
hot topic concern for pretty much
everybody to deal with on a daily basis
why is it even a human emotion
so anxiety is sort of the word we use to
describe everything going on for us
today and we we we feel that we're in a
new age of anxiety
you know i actually think in the whole
premise of my book is that we actually
really have the wrong story of anxiety
that anxiety isn't this malfunction
or a disease that actually anxiety is a
triumph of human evolution
and that takes a little unpacking
because anxiety
is not necessarily an anxiety disorder
and we've we've come to equate the two
so anxiety is an emotion
it's evolved like many other things to
be useful to us and actually the you
know when darwin wrote his theory of
evolution it was a it was there it was a
trilogy there were three parts to it and
the third part was called the expression
of emotion in man and animals and it was
all about emotion and its adaptive value
and so when you think of it from that
perspective well why would we have
evolved to have anxiety it seems like
this destructive terrible thing anxiety
is apprehension
this nervous feeling our you know the
physical thing feeling the bi the
thoughts
all of those responses it's but it's
apprehension about the uncertain future
which means that there's something
coming around the bend it could be bad
but it could also be good because it's
uncertain and anxiety actually prepares
us to avert disaster and make good
outcomes into reality and so anxiety
evolved to help us actually manage this
perhaps the most critical challenge of
humanity over our evolution which is
uncertainty things that we can't predict
things we can't uh protect ourselves
immediately from and it prepares us to
imagine the future that's why i called
the book future tense you can't be
anxious without thinking into the future
being a mental time traveler you imagine
the future you plan
and then result in in response to those
plans you're more persistent creative
innovative and you prioritize social
connections and so anxiety is really it
has this aspect of being a real asset to
us so anxiety is fundamentally future
focused you can't be anxious but we can
be anxious about something that happened
in the past oh no no what we would be
anxious about would be i went and had a
conversation with my
co-worker it went really really badly i
feel like a fool i am anxious about how
they are going to treat me the next time
that they see me so even the stuff that
we reflect on we're still going future
focused with it 100 that's right and so
and we think about anxiety because it's
so amorphous i mean language is so
crucial our mindset what we believe and
filter in about our world so we've all
come to assume that anxiety and and
honestly
the reason i wrote this book i mean i've
been a scientist for 20 years i'm a
researcher i'm a neuroscientist
and i thought oh all right we're going
to we're going to take great signs we're
going to beat back this mental health
crisis we're facing i actually became a
psychologist officially on september
11th 2001.
that's 9 11.
i was defending as the towers my defense
of dissertation as the towers were
falling i didn't know that i'm a new
yorker
and so here i am this newly minted
psychologist and i'm like okay we have a
crisis here i'm just going to put my
head down and do the science and create
the interventions and do the work and
then 20 years goes by and i look up and
mental health if anything is worse than
it was before it's been steadily
mental illness has been on the rise
we have great treatments we have
anti-anxiety meds if you need them we
have
science-based wellness practices we have
self-help we have a complete ecosystem
that is there to help us prevent and
eradicate anxiety but it's only been
getting stronger over the years and so i
realized that we've been doing something
fundamentally wrong as psychologists
we've been telling ourselves and others
that anxiety is a
malfunction that it's probably a disease
that the discomfort of anxiety should be
alarming to you and so suppress it right
away
prevent it eradicate it but that is
literally a recipe for making anxiety
worse when we avoid it when we suppress
it we know it always comes bouncing back
stronger
and
you don't develop ways of coping and you
forget that we can actually leverage
anxiety to be this incredibly useful
source of
activation and energy even though it
does feel bad it sucks energy i mean the
energy of anxiety does not feel good
but it evolved to feel bad so that it
grabs us makes us pay attention it's
that you know it's like a smoke alarm
going off telling us okay there's
something to care about in the world now
you better do your job and make it
happen
it's interesting when you look at
emotions or traits that we have that are
adaptive and fitness enhancing but also
uncomfortable and
the bottom line is
humans are built to be effective not
happy
right we're built to be effective
survive and reproduce survive and
reproduce what are the traits that
helped us to survive and reproduce now
we do have a mismatch right between our
current environment that we're in now
and the one that every single trait that
we now deal with developed in and in a
world which would have been
significantly more dangerous that would
have had far more threats where you
could have been killed by a cut on your
knee or there was constant predators
around and you didn't have shelter and
you were cold in the winter and hot in
the summer as opposed to the other way
around which we now have with heating
and air conditioning
um
all of those traits were adaptive right
they helped us to survive and anxiety
being everyone understand you walk
toward i do a little morning walk in
austin where i am at the moment and um
there's a lot of squirrels here you guys
everywhere i'm in new york we know we
know from squirrels intimately yes
and
there i was looking this morning i was
thinking about the fact we can have this
conversation and
it was i was so far away from this
squirrel it can move so much quicker
than i can move and yet
it was moving away from me scurrying
away from me
uh
because it's got presumably some form of
anxiety or concern or threat response
where it thinks that
big thing in the hoodie over there is
walking towards me i need to make sure
that i keep my distance even though
we're 10 yards apart
so there is always an advantage the
negativity bias right to er on the side
of
increased danger and i suppose that
yes seeing anxiety is something which is
malignant or a
like an aberration of the way that we're
put together is
probably not fully embracing what it can
do and also
maybe even more importantly than that as
soon as you start to make anxiety
a problem in itself you get anxious
guilty and resentful about feeling
anxious which creates this second order
effect that can often be even bigger
it's a recipe for that and something
very interesting about what you said in
which i spent a lot of time exploring in
the book
what you described about that squirrel i
believe that was probably closer to fear
than anxiety and we tend to equate the
two so fear
is
is present you're in the present tense
and you're certain there's danger right
there facing you and you don't have to
have simulations of the future you don't
have to be a mental time traveler here's
this big hoodie guy and he's coming
towards me and i'm this little squirrel
hey cutie and i need to do something
about that i've learned right that's
adaptive
but anxiety
is about something you haven't seen yet
it's about being able to simulate in
your mind and hold it at once both the
positive and the negative possibility
what if the hoodie guy comes by tomorrow
or next week
and i think i mean you'd have to be the
like the rene descartes of you know
you'd have to be you know you'd have to
be this existentialist squirrel to be
able to really think that deeply you
know about about um about that because
that's not you know the animals i think
do have some anxiety i mean of course
because i wrote a whole book about
anxiety i have a very anxious dog
that is a byproduct of you writing the
book i have no idea i can't figure it
out he's a rescue but but suffice it to
say when i think about his experiences
it's really about this certain present
danger and anxiety again you're thinking
to the future so it's not just
protective and that's something we can
wrap our mind around right like fear can
be protective too it's actually
productive and this is where we've been
asking the wrong questions having the
wrong conversations about anxiety
because well here's something that um
that's that's scientifically established
but we don't talk about it so we know
that uh that dopamine is sort of the
feel good hormone right it's that it's
that neurotransmitter in our brain we
think about it as having to do a dick
with addiction on the bad side but also
any sort of pleasure you get a spike of
dopamine right um it's sex drugs and
rock and roll that's dopamine
and we think about this reward system
which also is helpful to you because
dopamine also spikes when you're
anticipating pursuing something that's
important to you
trying to work towards a goal so
dopamine's there as this little
messenger among you know between your
brain areas trying to
get your brain to work effectively to
meet your goals
but guess what also causes dopamine to
strike to spike rather is anxiety so
when we're anxious dopamine
has a huge increase in our brain now why
because when we're anxious we still are
hoping we still we're in it to win it
we're caring about the future and so
anxiety by leveraging the reward system
is actually allowing us to say okay
there's this bad thing that could be
happening but there's also this really
good thing in my body which feels a lot
like fear right there's the fight flight
there's all these other things but those
are the fight flight and fear of the
three f's
anxiety on top of that recruits your
reward system it recruits your social
bonding system it recruits all this
other biology that allows us to be
positively focused not just defensive
does that mean that people can get
addicted to anxiety or they can become
dependent or increasingly sensitive to
it
well we actually have not asked a lot
about that it's a great question what we
think probably happens is that you know
when you're tracking your emotional
state uh you know anxiety you know it's
uncomfortable it spikes but so does
dopamine but then when you meet your
goal when you either do the thing you
need to you know you're worrying about
that thing in the future like oh i
better just take care of business
then when you've done that dopamine will
start to go down your anxiety will go
down and that's negative reinforcement
right so it can keep you
doing that same thing
and maybe that's a good thing like
persisting
um because the absence of that that that
feeling of anxiety
is is rewarding to you so in that sense
what you're suggesting is really
interesting because you're saying well
but if we get hooked on that cycle of
feeling good
right after we've done that thing
anxiety i mean that's one way that we
know anxiety disorders operate like take
uh uh what we now don't term an anxiety
disorder but an obsessive compulsive
related disorder ocd
the trick with ocd is that the
obsessions which are these disturbing
thoughts um and ideas we try to control
them with the compulsions the rituals
and so the rituals we get stuck on these
rituals because at least for a brief
moment they reduce our anxiety just in
the short term of course it comes
screaming back later even stronger than
ever but it's that negative
reinforcement cycle that keeps us hooked
into obsessions
what is apart from the dopamine what is
anxiety at a biological level what's
going on i feel anxiety what is being
deployed within my body what's happening
so you have you do have the autonomic
nervous system particularly you know the
fight flight system that's activated so
on the kind of peripheral biology that's
what you're having uh
what you see happening you also though
you have your central nervous system you
have your brain activating and a lot of
people um you know because
mostly because we scientists have talked
about it this way we think oh you're
anxious or fearful and your amygdala
starts firing this fear center of your
brain but the amygdala which is this
sort of part of this limbic emotional
area of our brain it's much more than
just a fear detector it um detects
uncertainty it also detects reward and
at when you receive treatment for
anxiety disorders it's it's as if the
amiga is representing all these
important things in the world to us not
negative positive uncertain and when
you're treated for an anxiety disorder
that proportion shifts so you start to
maybe you are over emphasizing
uncertainty and negativity and then when
you get your anxiety a little more roped
in you actually start focusing more on
the reward aspects of what why anxiety
is driving you so you have the amygdala
you have the limbic system but you also
have these cortical olympic circuits in
the brain which connect the emotional
brain with the prefrontal cortex and so
that circuitry is crucial because it's
the prefrontal cortex and other areas in
the temporal you know temporal lobe that
allows you to
regulate your emotional experiences it
allows you to bring in memories
um the prefrontal cortex also allows you
to be guided by your and there's no chi
in the background i'm guided about
guided by your your values your goals
these higher order things that can drive
us and give us a sense of purpose so
anxiety doesn't just make the amygdala
fire it recruits this whole
brain circuitry this beautiful elaborate
a multi-layered aspect of who we are as
human and and we just sort of put it in
this kind of we shuttle we shuttled it
aside and sort of said oh no it's just
fear and all the negative stuff but it's
all this other stuff too is there some
adrenaline dump in there too is there
anything else going on
when you have a sort of fight flight
response definitely there's this i mean
and if you think about how anxiety feels
i mean everyone knows how it feels right
it's it's the heart racing it's the
butterflies in the stomachs and you know
the word anxiety came from
much older words like uh angere which is
latin for choking and so you also have
that sort of you know when you're when
all of a sudden you like kick in your um
your sympathetic nervous system that
branch that fight flight system of the
autonomic nervous system you know you
can sometimes cho you know feel that
like tension um so it definitely
activates that as well but
really what anxiety is helping us do is
navigate uncertainty so if you think
about that we think oh in this stressful
terrible world you know anxiety of
course it's spiking because there's so
much uncertainty there's so much it's a
poor match with how we evolved to be in
reality but really in that sense because
we have so much uncertainty now on so
many different kinds of levels anxiety
is still this incredible ally because
it's an uncertainty detector the minute
we face something and you know a second
from now is the future so it doesn't
have to be a year in the future or a
month the minute we detect something
that's uncertain anxiety is there to
focus us in on the positive
possibilities both positive and negative
energize us activate us
and and it's there to help us navigate
at this ever-changing world i'm not sure
if
i would say that there is more
uncertainty
in modernity than there would have been
ancestrally but there's definitely more
complexity and complexity i think can
maybe
display
as uncertainty but i i know unless all
hell breaks loose that i should be okay
waking up tomorrow morning the predators
at the door
um
one of the things that i wonder is
let's say that i go to sleep tonight but
i'm not going to sleep with a dog
snoring near me and a fire crackling
both of which have been shown to improve
the depth of people's sleep and
presumably that's because ancestrally if
you had fire and you had a dog that
would mean that you could afford to go
into deeper sleep fewer micro awakenings
you're going to be able to be more
responsive um
the problem is
maybe
the real
increase in actual safety and certainty
that we have
i'm more certain i would much sooner be
in this locked bedroom than have a fire
and a dog but out in wilderness right
um but i just don't know if this if our
systems are accepting that so even
though certainty uh from a sort of
rational perspective has perhaps gone up
first off it's maybe mismatched with
what our body detects as certainty and
safety uh and then on top of that there
is absolutely more complexity right
there is way way way more noise and far
less signal
what we consume on a daily basis um as
well what you said about how the
amygdala and the front brain are
connecting makes a lot of sense because
what you're doing usually when you're
getting anxious is creating these
elaborate
dreams nightmares scenarios in which
everything goes wrong but you need to
recruit a big chunk of brain power right
to be able to do you it's this super
colorful and you can almost feel it you
can hear what it would be like walking
across the floor to speak to your boss
to have the conversation and what the
door looks like and the handle looks
like in your opening and that's his face
in front of whatever it is right that
you're doing awkward conversation with
your partner um that takes a lot of
imagination right so
i suppose in one way anxiety is a a
pretty uh complex and sort of high
processing recruitment
uh
thing for our brains to do
yeah that's i mean that's why i think of
it as a triumph of human evolution
because that being a simula being able
to do mental simulations in exquisite
detail like you described that is a very
human evolutionary achievement that i
believe is probably unique to humans
among other among other animals you know
the thing is it's a really great point
about certainty in the nature of
certainty and uncertainty and we think
of and of course
we had much a much longer time to evolve
being concerned about certainty with
basic safety
threats you know and all of this
but we also
have evolved to be highly adaptive to
what a different you know a different
context or a new context throws our way
and and that's why you know there's a
whole chapter in the book
that i just call uncertainty i don't
actually use the word anxiety until the
very end of the chapter because really
what anxiety is it's solving the problem
of uncertainty for us
because that and you know we may have
our physical well-being taken care of
but when we're in this complex world as
you as you know all of a sudden there
are all these other concerns that we
consider to be life and death
will we have status
will we have
relationships we've been taught to
believe that there are you know there
are these standards
of um what it means to be well you know
these sort of toxic standards of
positivity right that if you fall short
of some perfection of being happy or
content all the time then it's just a
failure and so these are sort of they
are not survival needs but the human
brain perceives these kinds of goals
that we've we have decided are central
to what it means to live a happy life as
being almost like survival so i agree
with you there's so much that's more
certain
but the level of complexity information
flow and uncertainty in other higher
order domains i just wonder if it sort
of uh evens it out in a way
how do you see anxiety relating to
stress
so anxiety is an emotion stress is not
stress is about this combination of
it's a it's the it's our belief
um that we can handle
and cope with certain events in the
world combined with the actual demands
of uh the world is put upon us so stress
is never just
um you know i i went down stairs and
there's union square park in manhattan
right below me and um i walked out there
and someone you know pushed me
um and um that's very stressful and it's
also aggressive and you know so stress
is that burden or that experience that
requires you to respond right but it's
also your belief that you can handle it
so me all five foot almost five foot
four of me you know i tend to i tend to
believe uh that i i have a lot of power
in this world i believe that if someone
really came at me i'd get that
adrenaline rush and be able to take them
on and i would probably unwisely
you know i'd feel like i could defend
myself and so when that person pushes me
and runs away i might feel a little less
stressed than a person
who doesn't believe that they have what
it takes to handle a confrontation so
it's always this your your personal
perception of what you can uh how much
control you have how much ability and
the experience itself
that's just not anxiety anxiety is this
picturing the future there's threats and
there's rewards
it's interesting that you talk about
stress through the same
um
lens that one of my friends uh james
smith he's got a book how to be
confident coming out soon and i think
one of his
fundamental
assertions is that confidence is your
ability to know that you can deal with
any challenges that come up and face you
so there is some sort of
cash
flow system that you have in your mind
around what is what is the challenge
what is my capacity to meet the
challenge
uh and i do think that i do think that
you're right anxiety just seems to be
less
rational i mean even less rational than
stress is kind of impressive but it it
does manage to remove you you're not
thinking about
unless you get very conscious about it
unless you're breathing deep and you're
trying to formally move through a
process
you don't really think like oh but think
about all of the previous times that
i've got through this i know this one's
going to be different this time's going
to be the catastrophe that means
whatever
and it's also hilarious to think about
how uh acute the anxiety response is to
something which totally has absolutely
nothing to do with anything that we
really genuinely care about long term
right so it's a lot of stuff to do with
social comparison let's say you post a
stupid uh comment on your friend's
instagram page and you think oh
everyone's gonna see that and it's gonna
make me look dumb or you find out that
one of your friends has unfollowed you
but yeah you have this this sort of
anxiety dumped the same way as if you
needed to have a fight tomorrow
um
well you know that's interesting i would
take issue with that a little if i heard
you correctly that you think that
anxiety is less rational than stress
i don't know i i would say that our
ability to to interject into anxiety
anxiety to me seems to be more acute it
seems to be
more difficult to pattern interrupt when
it's occurring and perhaps that's simply
because it is more acute and stress
tends to be a little bit more chronic
and long-term
um
i
maybe they're both
let me give you an example if i may that
i and i'm wondering what you're going to
think of this so you know anxiety any so
evolutionary theories about emotion and
actually the kind of emotion scientist i
was trained to be uh it's called a
functional emotion theorist
so the whole idea of functional emotion
theory is that emotions are profoundly
rational that they've and this is really
drawing on darwin that they evolved to
give us information
which we call which is called appraisal
in the theory and action readiness
tendencies and they're so automatic that
they save energy so they're efficient so
for example anger is the appraisal the
information that you have a desired goal
that's blocked
and it's the action so once you you've
said okay i'm angry because this thing i
want there's an obstacle to it it's
blocked for me and that appraisal that
information creates the action readiness
tendency to overcome the obstacle so it
prepares you to fight to do what you
need to do to persist
and so that's fundamentally rational
right now and it's also automatic and
efficient and so the way i think about
anxiety is that it's this automatic
appraisal that this future is uncertain
and it's but it's something i care about
so your example about posting something
stupid on instagram and i don't even do
social media really that much anymore
because i just can't get past the
like how do i do this and it's really
you know and i don't know what to say
and i feel like i'm a brand and that's
i'm a gen xer so that's fundamentally
aversive to me anyway um but you know
you that if you had that feeling if you
posted something and you thought it was
stupid anxiety is the information that
you care about that you care about
looking stupid on instagram
i personally
like may not or let's not talk about me
anyone someone who can post something
and just blindly post anything they want
on and they just don't care they won't
get anxious about it because anxiety
points you you can only be anxious when
you care about something so it's that
information
and imagine uh i don't know if you ever
have this happen but
um you know you wake up at 5 a.m and you
have those worries it's like
free-floating anxiety going through your
head right so you sit there and you can
do one of two things you can say oh my
god i have to have to get rid of this
because it's painful it's unpleasant or
you can say there's some information for
me in here let me let me what what's
going through my mind here so you might
sit there and say oh wait a second is it
that fight i had with my partner last
night and you're like no we resolved
that you're like okay what a is it
something up that work thing that i have
to do
no that's that's okay too and then you
you're and then you're feeling it oh
wait a second i've been waking up every
morning with searing pain in my stomach
for two weeks
oh maybe i should be caring about that
and maybe i should go to the doctor
yep that's it bingo
so so anxiety is giving us this
information about what we care about and
when we listen to it and interpret it as
useful
it can be an incredible
help mate to us so there's this
beautiful study that was done by jamison
and colleagues in 2013 there um out of
harvard also matt knock and other
colleagues
and they brought in socially anxious
patients so people diagnosed with social
anxiety disorder and when you have
social anxiety disorder the key concern
is that you fear social rejection and
judgment
and so they brought in this group of
people and then they prepared them to do
what is literally a torture session for
a socially anxious person um which is to
in three minutes prepare a speech
about something very contentious
probably like the death penalty or
something like that um and present it
after this brief preparation in front of
a panel of judges who will be evaluating
you on your performance and they're and
all the judges are sitting there like
that so this is a torture session for
someone who's socially anxious
and so and they have this and they're
getting ready to do this and their
hearts are racing and then they take
half of them
aside just half and the other half are
left they take half of them aside and
say okay listen you're going to feel
your racing heart and your butterfly all
those feelings you're sweating
that's not
about you know that's not the feeling
that you're about to fail that's not a
malfunction that's actually your body
performing
what it needs to do it's preparing to be
at peak performance
it's actually your blood pumping through
your veins so that your brain can be
sharper it's actually you know it's just
you know and so there's this mindset re
resetting that was happening they were
also given some scientific articles just
in case they didn't believe it and
they're like see these five scientific
articles that show this and darwin's
evolutionary theory and etc so they get
10 or 15 minutes of this
and then they do this this um of folks
who didn't get this information about
the adaptive value of anxiety they do it
to and they were monitoring heart rate
and blood pressure and performance
during the speech and what do you find
the half of these socially anxious
people who are forced to do what is a
torture session for them their heart
rates
are slower than the other half of the
group their blood pressure is lower
they perform better they stutter less
they they're more confident
essentially they look more like people
who are kind of brave and preparing to
act and doing their best in that peak
performance than than people who are
overwhelmed by anxiety biologically and
in terms of performance and so this was
all this was
was
helping these folks take in anxiety as
information and reframing what that
information meant to them and they were
actually then able to leverage it
what's the lesson that you take away
from that uh from a
uh applied sense
well interestingly james and colleagues
are developing a whole intervention for
social anxiety based on this concept
it's sort of the sole purpose of my book
which is
it's not really a self-help book in the
traditional sense there aren't tons of
tips or it's really a mindset shift it's
really the idea that right now
our view of anxiety our language about
anxiety our assumptions
and um what we believe anxiety to be
the role it plays in our life
these beliefs are setting us up for
failure they're making us do things that
make anxiety worse like avoid anxiety
have meta fear and meta worry you know
you know and um and so
if we can reconsider
our what anxiety is what that there are
advantages as well as really just being
terrible too because it feels no one
wants to be anxious so that's not the
argument
i but by making this mindset shift you
can actually learn better to cope with
anxiety you can benefit more from
treatments if you do have clinical
anxiety and need that extra support and
you can actually start using anxiety in
your life almost like this sort of
alchemical process where you can take
that energy take that that emotion
understand what you care about leverage
it to hope and to work hard and to
persist and to be more creative that you
have that opportunity that you didn't
have when you thought about anxiety
differently so this can be directly
embedded in a treatment approach
existing treatment approach and jamison
and colleagues are developing whole new
treatment approaches just formalizing
that kind of an instruction to people
mindset shift it's interesting talking
about how the framing that you place
around the emotions that you're feeling
or the state that you're in
kind of fundamentally changes
what it is right i have a friend bridget
fettesey who's a comedian and she
started doing comedy relatively late and
she gets super super nervous before she
goes up on stage and she has a little
mantra that she says to herself before
she goes up on stage and she's saying
inside of her own head i'm not nervous
i'm excited i'm not nervous i'm excited
precisely that's precisely it and it's a
small nudge but those kinds of nudges
many many times over
repeated over time they're incredibly
powerful
i'm not nervous i'm excited it's such a
good reframing before you've got to go
and get something
yeah and that's the spectrum of anxiety
anxiety is not a light switch on and off
it's it's a dimmer it's a dimmer switch
and on that spectrum yes there's panic
yes there's overwhelming anxiety but on
the other end of the spectrum there's
this trees on of this kind of excitement
this wait i'm kind of in it to win it i
care about this thing i mean talk to any
performance artist like your friend you
know like your friend any comedian any
dancer any performer
and many of them will tell you if i'm
not throwing up in the bathroom before i
go out on stage something's wrong it
means i don't care about it and what
i've learned the performer might say is
that that signal is is getting me ready
and it doesn't mean that i'm about to
fail or there's a malfunction another
friend who is supporting eric prince on
a world tour and has been for years and
years and years he used to play for us
in newcastle and before he goes on stage
he's always very very close to a toilet
and this is a guy that's played madison
square garden on new year's eve right
he's played the biggest gigs ever and
he's been doing this for 15 years and
he's one of the most competent
hard-working people that i know and yet
every single time before he's about to
go on stage he still has that and
it almost gets but this is where you can
see how superstitions and rituals of
football players
start to form right well i put the left
sock on then the right sock on then i
did a double bow on the the left foot
but not on the right foot we don't do
that and then i touch the top of the
tunnel as i go out all of these sort of
bizarre rituals and superstitions are
part of that
frame setting that pre-game routine that
gets them from perhaps nervous to
excited to performing to flow
exactly and you know i w i wish now in
retrospect that i'd had a whole chapter
on on sports in this book because
it's so clear that this mastery
of anxiety having it owning it and using
it that that this kind of mastery is
central to i think sport greats and
elite athletes and you know and they
have those rituals all those rituals are
are tools to channel
you know and sort of transform
that that anxiety into something that
they can work with what mistakes did
medicine make when it comes to
identifying anxiety facilitating it
explaining it to the public
i think the biggest thing is you know
the prime fallacy that we mental health
professionals really for the better part
of 100 years really since freud and even
before that
the prime fallacy is that any experience
of anxiety is a malfunction or disease
right
and so we don't know anymore how to
distinguish between anxiety and an
anxiety disorder and the key distinction
is not the level of anxiety so you you
don't get diagnosed with an anxiety
disorder if you have ex you know high
levels of anxiety
you know even on a frequent basis the
only time you'll be diagnosed with an
anxiety disorder is if the way you cope
with your experiences of anxiety start
to get in your way so that if you um are
socially anxious and
you cope with that anxiety
by not going outside anymore not going
to any parties not being able to go to
work it's that it's it's those ways of
coping that actually that functional
impairment which is what you call it
when you're diagnosing someone it's that
that is a synonym of an anxiety disorder
um there's a beautiful um you know i'm
also a child psychologist by training
and so i think a lot about kids and
families and um and there's this great
treatment
that takes this as a starting premise
coming out of the yale child study
center ellie leibowitz and his
colleagues it's called space
it's it's about helping parents
help their kids
just experience and tolerate anxiety so
he'll you know so this treatment what it
involves is um you'll bring
clinically anxious kids so kids with
anxiety diagnoses
into the clinic and you know in some of
these controlled trials half of the kids
will get gold standard cognitive
behavioral therapy which is some of the
best therapy out there
the other half won't instead their
parents will be taught to stop over
accommodating
anxiety in their kids what does that
mean
the kid who's afraid to fly parents who
out of the best of intentions want to
comfort the child
will stop all family vacations that
require taking a flight somewhere um the
kid who's you know who doesn't want to
be separated from the parent they'll say
well okay you don't have to go to school
today and you don't have to go tomorrow
and you don't have to go the next day
that's accommodation of anxiety in a way
that's actually not helping and we know
makes anxiety worse so the parents are
simply taught to stop that and instead
support the kids and actively coping
with all the discomfort of anxiety and
all the distress and what you find is
after the parents get that six weeks of
treatment and you compare them the kids
of those parents to kids who got
treatment themselves
80 percent i think that one of the first
studies they did 87
of those kids whose only their parents
received therapy showed significant
reduction in reductions in clinical
anxiety they did as well as the kids who
got therapy themselves so if you did if
you were able to combine the cbt with
the parents therapy
no there's no cbt for the kids no but is
there not cbt on the control group
no
it's only oh i'm sorry so in the
comparison well yes so that there were
so the kids half of them just got cbt
yes and then the other half just got the
parent right so what the magic uh
combination should be both yes that's
what i was that's what i was thinking
what is
what's a what's
how heritable is anxiety that why why do
you have a an anxious child and not an
anxious other child have you got any
idea about heritability
there's there's good evidence that
anxiety disorders again this is the
extreme of the spectrum are only
moderately and probably mildly heritable
which suggests that there's probably a
genetic and temperament component but
it's so much more
sort of how you know what you bring to
the world matches with the demands that
are thrown at you the stressors that are
thrown at you combined with how you
learn to cope with that
so you know for example i have two kids
a 13 year old son and a 10 year old
daughter and my boy my son's going to
kill me one day but he's a little more
on the anxious side and there are
several stories about sort of that
anxious experience that he's always
brought to the table there's stories
about how much how terribly i have
failed in helping him with that but i
know that you know part of that
is him part of that is the fit with my
parenting style and part of that's the
what we help him how we help him cope
how effective is anti-anxiety medication
i think that for many people
anti-anxiety meds are a really important
temporary step
and you know benzodiazepines are they
were really a revolution when they were
created about uh 70 80 years ago now of
course they were stumbled upon it was by
mistake um that's the story there do you
know the story yeah so
um so um
prior to benzodiazepines um
um you know the treatments for anxiety
were were very uh very dangerous you
know so there are these tr essentially
these these tranquilizers minor
tranquilizers that were given to people
um barbiturates um to treat anxiety so
judy garland and marilyn monroe died of
barbiturate overdoses which were
anti-anxiety myths because they
suppressed the central nervous system so
if you take too much you're combined
with alcohol you stop breathing your
heart stops beating so this was sort of
the go-to treatment um and doctors
having medicalized you know anxiety to
be oh it's a disease we better treat it
you know really wanted some way to
relieve people's pain they didn't think
about how do we help them through it so
luckily um there was the uh discovery of
benzodiazepines and essentially what
happened is you know there
these researchers um
and pharmacists they were trying to
create a better uh drug and they finally
gave up they were working working and
one of the uh scientists literally just
left his mess uh on a bench like on a
scientific bench and went away for three
months and finally someone was sent in
to clean it up and they found i'm not a
chemist uh but they found these
beautiful like well crystallized i guess
little compounds
and they started looking at them
and it turned out these were
benzodiazepines and so now what you have
is you have what they believed at the
time to be less addictive
um to be um
to be more tolerated well tolerated and
very effective in reducing anxiety so
the first anti-anxiety med was valium
and you know it became so popular in the
50 this was in the 50s that they had
discovered it in the 50s and 60s and 70s
you know they the doctors would just
prescribe it and call it v it was valium
um you know the rolling stone song
mother's little helper that was valium
um it used to be called executive
excedrin you know the painkiller
excedrin because all the executives and
business people would be popping it as
they went across you know across
across the world in their business trips
and everyone was very optimistic and
hopeful but then what started to happen
is we realized that benzodiazepines were
very dangerous as well
and they are addictive and they are also
nervous system depressors so that means
again if you combine them with say
opioids
or you combine them with alcohol
they can
they can cause coma and death um what we
see and there's there was a really
interesting uh a lot of awareness in
general but there was an interesting
piece that came out in complex magazine
a little while back a few years back i
was actually interviewed for it and it
was it was about the crisis of um of
anti-anxiety meds in the hip-hop
community and so what you see is a lot
of these hip-hop stars were starting to
take
anti-anxiety meds
um
all the time but they were all on
percocet xanax
yeah and there was that guy little xan
do you remember little xan i think he
renamed himself soundcloud rapper yeah
he's recently he was a soundcloud rapper
all the soundcloud rappers he's recently
just called out his manager a guy with
the name little zan
called out his manager for providing him
with drugs i'm like
but one of my favorite rappers juice
world oh god i was going to talk about
juicy i have a whole section on him in
my book because that is a tragedy and he
was
so talented like i adore it satisfies
two two very big parts of me the one
part which is to be cool and to listen
to rap and the other part of me which is
still an emo from when i'm 15. it's a
perfect mix
it's exactly what i've always wanted and
i love it and i discovered in posting
like posthumously i'm like no hang on
hang on a second like i what there's no
more
there's no there's going to be no more
of this it's so sudden he was
coming off his private jet
that's well that is a whole story that's
right and
i mean here's the thing and it enrages
me
in many ways about
how we've taught our young people to
think about emotional pain and physical
pain right that it that we need to
eradicate it
so
juice world you know he was singing
about
his emotion i mean that's what makes
these soundcloud rap rappers and emo
rappers and not i mean lil peep died of
the same kind of an overdose i mean this
is wiping out this generation of artists
and you know it used to be the 27 club
right like jimi hendrix and janice
joplin all these these rock stars who
died at 27 now it's the 21 club because
these kids are taking these meds and
they're trying to crush their emotional
and physical pain and it's killing them
and so juice world would be singing like
you know um you know i have you know
uh i have what's what's the what's
there's there's this song where he's
talking about
um feeling right oh righteous he's
feeling you know he's he's in his white
gucci suit he's feeling righteous he has
all these pills in his hand and he has
codeine overflowing on his nightstand i
mean he's that is that is the song he's
talking about his anxiety the size of a
planet he's talking about things and in
his song bad energy he's talking about
how he feels like i feel you know i'm
winning why do i'm winning but i feel
like i'm losing well was that not the
same with avicii as well
100
and so what is you know so in in some
ways the reason i wrote this book
is to say listen if we're always talking
about anxiety and emotional pain and
distress is something fundamentally
dangerous not only are we wrong about
that because there's a real advantage if
we listen to it but we're also creating
this strategy of constantly numbing that
pain of constantly eradicating and
avoiding it this is that disease model
what would you say to people that say
who you to say that anxiety is an
advantage look at what downstream from
it it's killed people it makes me feel
terrible
i have anxiety and stuff like that how
can you try and tell me that my pain is
something which is an advantage to me
it's a crucial question and my answer to
that is that
anxiety disorders are real
they're incredibly painful and people
need to get support for them i am i'm i
think we need to give complete
acknowledgement of that i mean that's
what i've devoted my life to
at the same time
i also believe that anxiety is not
always a disorder
that it is an emotion that
actually is prepared to be helpful to us
that that when even though it can spiral
out of control when we learn to master
it not by eradicating it or numbing it
but by
leaning into it by examining it it then
can actually yield its benefit to us
but when we avoid it and that is the
crucial problem with anxiety disorders
when we chronically avoid and we cope in
ways that are actually just trying to
push away these experiences of anxiety
we're only going to make it worse so
even if you do have an anxiety disorder
shifting your mindset can help you bring
some of that back own it more so it
doesn't own you and benefit more from
treatments that are already out there i
mean actually i am it's not even just me
saying this so a soren kicker guard the
philosopher the danish philosopher 180
years ago wrote
to learn to be anxious in the right way
is to learn the ultimate
which shows from his perspective and one
i believe that anxiety is a feature of
being human it's not a bug and there is
a right way to be anxious and we can
figure that out
in what ways do you think technology's
contributed to the modern anxiety
epidemic
i think that anxiety and digital
technology there is a relationship there
as a scientist i know and uh that we
have overstated that relationship and
oversimplified it so if you read the
headlines it's you know
uh you know social media have destroyed
a generation or
um you know tick tock is cause instagram
is causing uh mental illness in people
and it's really never that quite simple
um one is that there's no there are
actually no data to actually show that
if you go in out with everything else
being equal you use social media and you
become more anxious and more depressed
it's much more of a linchpin in those
problems or digital technology and
you're struggling and you're anxious and
you're depressed
we can use things uh these social media
in ways that actually make it worse so
uh for example there where we do have
some good research um it shows that it's
the way you use social media not so much
how much you use that makes a difference
and people have divided the ways into
the kind of the active passive
distinction so when you're using social
media in active ways
you're actually creating something
you're seeking out information you're
you're doing something that's much more
goal directed and uh usually something
that's also
actually leveraging your creative powers
passive use is when we're tuning out
we're using technology like a big uh you
know avoidance machine right just this
giant way of just it's like just eating
a bag of chips right we're just we're
doom-scrolling
we're like re-posting you know other
people's stuff or social com we're like
counting how many likes we have and
we're doing social comparisons when we
use social media in passive ways like
that that tends to accelerate and
exacerbate things like anxiety so what i
see the problem of being is that
we have to shift away from black and
white ways of thinking about technology
and just you know we have to become good
digital citizens we have to say listen i
well i personally believe that that tech
companies need to change their
algorithms i mean they're not for human
good they're just for their bottom line
profit so i think those algorithms and
all the toxicity of these of these
platforms is a problem but
until we can figure that out we need to
be empowered to make choices and to know
hey just like i know i need to eat
fruits and vegetables and once in a
while salt and vinegar chips which is my
favorite um you know we have to make the
same choices about social media we have
to know that if we're doom scrolling all
day it's going to make us feel bad it's
going to make us feel crappy whereas if
we create some really exciting content
or a podcast or we're doing something
really interesting that's going to
elevate us and elevate others around us
what are your thoughts about the insight
jonathan hate got when he managed to
align i think it's about 2012 2013 the
introduction of instagram with this huge
spike in terms of
young female anxiety and that wasn't
mirrored across into men have you
thought about this a lot and i have
critiqued those data heavily and this is
really bring it on send it come on i
think john hate is a great i think john
hate is a great scientist i mean he came
out of a different field of study you
know he's he's uh his you know he really
studies moral reasoning and um and has
done amazing work i think his work on
you know i think his book the coddling
of the american mind is a very
important and interesting one um i think
his work in political uh you know
political psychology is very important
but here's where i think he's getting it
wrong now he's actually citing a lot of
gene twenge's work that he and gene
tuenke have joined forces
and she is a social psychologist who has
conducted um kind of take in large
epidemiological data sets what do you
mean when you say large epidemiological
data sets
survey data that that she didn't in most
cases actually gather and and you have
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
people and then you start to look for
correlations among things and so and she
tracks and she tracks these sort of
generational shifts and that's part of
the work that she's contributed to
psychology but where i feel she's gone a
step too far and where i think john hate
is is also looking at some of those data
is to say okay well we do see that
there's a correlation between the
introduction of the mo of mobile phones
um and this sort of spike in
anxiety and depression
that
seems to be carried by by girls um and
you can also look at you see
correlations between amount of
technology use and these kinds of
symptom profiles
number one um these were not
data that were about clinical anxiety or
depression in most cases so these are
again these are existing data sets so
these are not clinical studies of actual
clinical anxiety and depression number
two a great group out of oxford actually
had access to those same data sets
because they're publicly available and
they did a re-analysis and they found
that the effect size of the link between
technology and say anxiety or depression
was quite small and they could also find
a similarly powerful effect size a link
between eating potatoes and mental
health so the more you ate potatoes the
more anxious and depressed you were and
it was literally
at the same
level of correlation as the link between
technology and anxiety and depression
now all that to say i don't think that
rules out the fact or the possibility
that there could be a strong link i
think that digital technology and social
media
i see lots of negative potential
negative impacts but to say that there's
a simple causal all streams are bad link
between
mental health
and digital technologies we just don't
have the data i think it's more useful
to get nuanced and to say well what
kinds of use are problematic and for
whom and why so these large data sets
are that's actionable and there's also a
lot of ways to reinterpret the data
i remember seeing a bunch of very
strange correlations online that's to do
with the graph and i swear that one of
them was the number of movies that
nicolas cage starred in in a year and
the number of people that died by
overdosing on cheese
so give given the right data set pretty
much such beautiful things but
there was another one of like um the
number of songs released by the rolling
stones and the number of people who
suffocated tangled up in their own bed
sheets
so i am i mean i just think uh honestly
i think when we draw such strong
conclusions from correlational data we
should be laughed at
because it should be just hypothesis
generating it should be okay
yeah we should go and and it's hard to
test some of these things but it's hard
work and we have to do that hard work
perspective
studies and we have to get nicolas cage
to
get in a new movie so that we can
experimentally control what happens
after precisely correct there was um
one of the things i think is interesting
around how
that link between technology and the way
that we feel after we use technology um
is
the expectation effect which is a new
book by david robson came out a couple
of months ago he's on the show he's
fantastic science communicator
the placebo effect which everyone is
familiar with this is basically that but
scaled across everything and anything
that you care to care about and the best
example that he gave was
um gluten intolerances have gone up by
uh ten times from three percent to
thirty percent over the last 15 years
and they brought people into a study
they sat them down some people did and
did not have biological gluten
intolerances some people did and did not
have self-reported gluten intolerances
they gave everybody the same meal and
they told everybody that had gluten in
it but it had no gluten in it and you
ended up with people in a study who
didn't have a biological gluten
intolerance who hadn't eaten gluten
coming out with hives having
inflammation having diarrhea having to
go to the bathroom and that basically
scales across everything and
i think the the episode's so powerful
tons and tons of people really really
loved it the reason being i think that
it reminds us that we have way way way
more control through framing right how
are you framing the experience that you
go through and i'm pretty adamant that
part of the discussion that we're having
around social media is that we've been
told that these tech companies are
malign and they're stealing our
attention and it's bad for our memory
and it's bad for our long-term health
and it's bad for our dopamine levels and
stuff like that but the problem is that
that creates an expectation effect for
everybody
so you start to use your phone and you
finish up and you feel guilty about your
phone use and you expect to feel bad oh
well here comes the dopamine crash off
the back end of being on instagram for a
couple of hours or whatever and you go
well yeah of course like
it's it's so difficult right because you
don't want to do false reporting like if
there is a negative uh result that comes
from using technology you can't lie
about it but by making it public you
make people begin to expect it more
which further it's like a recursive loop
that just always makes it worse and
worse and worse i don't really know how
to pattern interrupt that but i
certainly know that
taking into account look you have
control over the framing and framing is
in some situations literally more
important than the thing that actually
happened so there was this
the other my other favorite study from
it was he had uh people sit on a bike
and do a vo2 max test which is a pretty
ugly fitness test to do
and
they did in advance genetic marker
testing apparently there's a particular
type of genetic marker that means that
your up regulation of oxygen in your
lungs is better and you can blow off co2
more efficiently now they split the
group into split the study into two
different groups but these people
weren't based on the genetics but they
took one group to one side that had
people who didn't didn't have that
genetic marker in and said
you should do really well on this test
you've got the right genetics that are
going to make it easier and they said to
the other group of people some that
didn't some that didn't uh you've got
the bad genetics you you're probably not
going to do very well in this test then
they got them to do the vo2 max test and
looked at the results afterwards now
like surprise surprise the people that
were told that they had the right
genetics they performed better what was
more interesting was that when they
actually looked at the up regulation of
what was going on in their lungs their
blood pressure their hiv their heart
rate all that stuff they found that the
people that were told that they had the
right type of gene
outperformed the people who had the
right gene
so literally what they believed was more
powerful than their genetics
that blew my mind i i mean i i'm with
i'm with you 100 on this and the data
just keep rolling in on this right and
that's why you know when you ask the
question about what would you know what
if someone who has an anxiety disorder
tells you you don't you know how can you
say this about anxiety
my answer is that
this mindset shift about anxiety to
actually see
that it can make you more creative and
persistent and hopeful
it can make you more creative and
persistent and hopeful and it can help
you if you're struggling and trying to
get therapy or trying to do wellness or
exercise or whatever it is you're doing
it can't this mindset set shift can help
you benefit more from that and that
literally that's the sole purpose of my
book i really don't want it to be a
self-help book only a mindset shift book
i guess that's self-help i sort of
resist the self-help category
what do most people get wrong when it
comes to trying to deal with anxiety
they presume that as soon as they feel
it they should manage it and suppress it
so really if we think about anxiety as
as information the very first
step needs to be that if it's
information listen to it
so whether that means like in the that
experiment i mentioned with socially
anxious people when okay i'm going to
listen to my heart racing and rather
than assume i'm about to fail at this
public speech i know it's preparing me
or that i care about this you know
listen to that information uh when
you're having free-floating anxiety
something's gonna something's gonna come
to your mind that tells you what you
care about and what you need to work
towards so listen to it
it's not always helpful information so
sometimes after we listen we realize
okay
i just have to let this go
it's too much
it's you know uh it's uh it's it's just
me spiraling out and that's when we do
things that we know support our wellness
and for a lot of people that's exercise
alan kasden who's a ver one of the
founders of cognitive behavioral therapy
research in in the us
he once uh at this some 50th anniversary
you know uh kind of uh meeting said if
we psychologists really cared about
people and helping them the first thing
we do is get them all to exercise
and then we'd see what problems were
left over and we'd create boutique
targeted treatments for those problems
so for a lot of and why does that work
why does exercise work well there's
biological reasons but i believe when it
comes to anxiety it's also that we
remove ourselves from this future tense
that can grab us when we're in the
future and worrying and we immerse
ourselves in the present we find flow
we find relief maybe we like to um take
walks maybe we do mindfulness meditation
maybe we you know there's so many things
that we can do and we know what helps us
i write very bad poetry i love to write
poetry it gets me out of whatever
mindset i'm in and helps me immerse
myself in my own personal sense of flow
and so these are things we can all do
and then okay so then you're in the
present and then you can turn back to
anxiety and say okay if there's
something to do here how can i hitch it
to a sense of purpose
how can i use it to pursue what i care
about my goals purpose doesn't have to
be some ground vision it can just be
what makes your life meaningful and i
think back to the social media question
i think we do expect it to be bad in
many ways i think that's a good
correction because before we thought
that all those you know black turtleneck
uh you know saviors were there to help
us and clearly they were not there to
help us they were there to line their
pockets i mean that's just very clear or
that social media wouldn't look like it
looks
but you know we can um you know sort of
have this view with technology that you
know we're going to put it in its place
uh we're going to
um
you know understand where it's helpful
for us and where it's not um we're going
to stop treating ourselves like a brand
like a something to be consumed i think
that's where some of the concern is
because when all we can do especially
kids they're forming their identities
they're figuring it out
when they have to sell themselves like a
brand when they have to think how am i
going to be consumed and approved of in
this world it just distorts their
ability to find a purpose
that's about what gives their personal
life meaning beyond the likes and the
and the shares
what gives their life meaning in terms
of what's greater than themselves
what is something that makes them feel
alive that helps them find flow i think
the actual problem with a lot of social
media is that we lose we have so many
lost opportunities
to tune into those other things in our
life and so those opportunity costs can
start to get in the way so i think we
need to question many aspects of social
media and we also need to reignite
our ability to find purpose in life and
pursue it and help our kids do the same
so
anxiety can help you in that because it
helps you hope it helps you work hard
points you in the right direction so if
somebody if somebody does begin to feel
anxious if it was me if some one of my
friends were saying hey man i i just
i've got this sort of anxious thought
process
my prescription would be uh here's a
breath work practice that's going to
take five minutes and you're gonna do
box breathing
uh then it would be go for a walk then
it would be go to the gym then it would
be have a cold shower that would be my
prescription right i'm aware that you're
not trying to go super applied with this
but you've already mentioned training as
one of the things are there any other
practices
that you think people could do with
educating themselves around if they want
to mitigate their anxiety response
so i love all of those practices you
mentioned i would just put something on
the beginning and end of it so what i
didn't hear you say was well what is
your you know why are you anxious
you know what is going on in your life
can you is it telling you something is
that anxiety actually pointing you to
something because instead we all
habitually including we psychologists we
go to okay we better handle it
we better you know and that's completely
skipping over the part about finding out
if there's information to be learned so
i would say one really great practice is
how do you sit with anxiety even when it
really feels terrible and it does
anxiety always feels terrible that's its
nature to make us pay attention
how do you find a way to sit with it to
tolerate the distress and to know you're
still okay and to find out what you can
so for some people that's journaling for
some people that's talking to a
therapist or a good friend um for some
people
that might be um
just meditating and letting and letting
those thoughts arise instead of keeping
them down and taking all that energy and
all that
the stress of suppressing it just takes
a toll over time so those are you know
when we think about those three parts
listening
you know being in the present and and
kind of managing when we need to and
then the third part is really again
since anxiety wants to take me into a
future where there's my where actually
my dreams are coming true when all these
good things are happening
how do i leverage anxiety in this way
you know my husband about
he's in the entertainment industry he's
a producer on broadway and tv etc
and he had a very big work stress uh
about eight months ago and
i have anxiety around my own life but
i saw him and i was helpless to do
anything to help him it was really bad
it was some bad stuff he had to work
through and i was so overwhelmed with
that it was so toxic it was so i just
didn't even know what to do with it
and i tend to be more of a depressed
person than an anxious person so even
though i've written this book about
anxiety my real bugaboo is a little
different but they go hand in hand which
is a whole different conversation but i
realized that the only way i could work
through this anxiety which was feeling
very extreme to me
um in addition to talking to people was
and doing all those self-care was to
actually hitch it to a sense of purpose
which for me was to try to be a support
to my husband and to try to use whatever
skills i could
to to make sense of it so
i just i i decided because the anxiety
was was so present i'm gonna spend some
extra time and just i'm just gonna
listen to him i'm not gonna try to fix
it
i'm not you know maybe i will if he
wants me to but just be there for him in
ways that made me feel feel fulfilled
because for me being a good partner at
that moment was really a gave me a sense
of purpose and so i felt a little bit
more in control a little bit more um
well a little bit less uncertain maybe
because i knew that okay we can do this
together we can handle this together and
then i also started writing about this
and i actually wrote an essay and i
wrote you know i just got it all out and
i started formulating thoughts and ideas
and started discussing them and so i
found ways to sort of take what was
overwhelming to me and i felt completely
helpless to do anything about it and to
find some outlet for that some sense of
purpose maybe a little control but
and really just kind of um projecting
myself into a future where we would be
able to be past this so those are the
kinds of things that you know therapy is
great i think everyone should be in
therapy whether or not you think you
have a clinical anxiety disorder or not
um i think with you know with medication
sometimes we need it to help bring us
back down to baseline so we can benefit
from other treatments but that's like
giving someone a fish instead of
teaching them to fish medications like
benzodiazepines which we talked about
before can kill people if not used
properly and can be addictive
um they should be used temporarily and
they should be used in combination
optimally with with therapy and that's
when they're most powerful
i really want to know about the
relationship between anxiety and
repression now i i i need to learn it
yeah
which part of it the way that that when
we suppress anxiety it only grows no
just what you've said that there is a
relationship between anxiety and
depression
oh and depression i've heard repression
sorry
so it's really interesting because i was
a person who when i was a teenager
suffered from clinical anxiety and
um the thing about anxiety about sorry
when i i suffered from clinical
depression as a kid the thing about
depression and again it's sort of this
almost functional emotion analysis right
when you're depressed
you actually really you've gone through
a stage of really caring about
things you want in the world you have
dreams you have hopes but what
depression is is this feel feeling of
real
um of loss you've lost that ability to
get what you need and want in life
you have despair you don't believe that
those things are possible anymore
and and so this positive optimistic
focus you might have had has just been
dashed again and again and again and you
can't find the hope anymore um and so
what you often and so that's quite
different from anxiety where you're
still sort of in it to win it right
because you're still working to make
that positive thing come true so what
psychology has documented for a number
of decades is that there's a high rate
of comorbidity between anxiety and
depression about 50 of people who are
anxious also end up being depressed at
some time if they're clinically anxious
and what we think might be going on in
that in a way is
when you're anxious and you're like okay
i want these things i'm going to worry
about them i'm going to make them happen
i'm going to do everything i need to i'm
going to avoid threats uh you know i'm
just so anxious about succeeding in life
for example and it's a positive goal
it's a it's a it's a it's a really a
productive goal but
life throws you curveballs
you you fail
you
try to pick yourself back up you work
towards it you just can't quite manage
it you have some bad luck so there's a
series of things that happen externally
and then internally in terms of your
ability to find ways to cope and you
know it's really arrogant to say oh just
shift your mindset about anxiety and
everything will be okay and that's
really not what i'm saying because
sometimes life is just overwhelming you
suffer and you can't always
it's messy you're not always going to do
well and that's not a failure that's
that's a process
so sometimes when you're anxious and you
just can't keep working towards what you
dream of
you become hopeless you start to despair
and that's when it can flip into the
depression
end of the spectrum so the two it's just
sort of what are you working towards in
life what are your goals what are your
dreams and how you achieve them whether
you achieve them how you perceive the
obstacles your mindset about that those
are the kinds of things
um that can lead us towards problematic
anxiety and depression and also be the
ways in to help fix them as well you
mentioned that 50 of people ish that
have anxiety are going to become
depressed do you know if the reverse is
true do you know if the relationship
between depression being the first mover
is the same for anxiety it tends to be a
developmentally it tends to be anxiety
first followed by depression but it does
go the other way too and then of course
you have you have multiple comorbidities
so with depression there's also
um you know high rates of eating
disorders especially in in females um
there's high rates of addiction
in depression and anxiety as well so
it's all these you know
we it's it's always a double-edged sword
with mental illness it's always us
humans us messy humans trying to adapt
to what can be a terrible world
sometimes and a wonderful world and so
every
symptom
is just an attempt to adapt
so you know when we when we're anxious
and we become or when we have ocd and we
start developing all these compulsions
that start to get in our way it's just
our human nature to try to adapt to
overwhelming feelings and thoughts and
it's really effective for a short term
it's kind of miraculous if you think
about it but over time it just the costs
outweigh the benefits so every you know
i started my career uh studying child
maltreatment abused kids my very first
job was to go into the basement of child
protective services and actually read
the detailed reports of how kids were
abused and what they suffered and was
terri i mean literally to this day i get
the sick feeling in my stomach but this
was a center at the university of
rochester in the united states that was
starting to develop the science of
maltreatment to understand
how maltreatment happens how it affects
kids and how kids can be resilient and
how people can be resilient in the face
of it and so here i was reading
about this terrible maltreatment i mean
real suffering physical abuse sexual
abuse um you know neglect and then i
would go and i'd be working with these
kids in this sort of day therapy program
and i would see them and they're
beautiful and they're creative and yes
they were troubled but they were they
were still remarkable
how did that happen
how in the world did they have that
resilience i mean and and so what
happens is they adjust to what should
not be happening to them
they form weaknesses but they also form
strengths
and so every way of adapting some kids
become hyper vigilant for negativity in
the world around them right and that's
an adaptation it's helpful if you want
to prevent getting hit by your caregiver
right to know when they're about to get
angry but if it starts to generalize to
school
and you start getting in fights with
everyone because you're looking for
someone being hostile towards you that
gets in the way but you also a lot of
these kids there's great research to
show they also notice positivity more
too so they're ready to receive that
positive feedback as well so all of
these are double-edged swords and the
more that we think about our own
struggles as opportunities it's a
mindset shift the better we'll be able
to work with them and own them instead
of being owned by them you just
mentioned creativity there what's the
relationship between anxiety and
creativity oh it's so interesting so
um
so there's i'll just start with one
study that sort of illustrates um this
so there's this great study that came
out
around 2008 by de drew and colleagues
and they were interested in this idea
that anxiety
and and other emotions that they
consider activating activating meaning
they they get you revved up rather than
slow you down so that includes anger
anxiety happiness not just the positive
negative distinction is much less
important than how they activate you to
do things in the world and then
deactivating emotions are more like
sadness or boredom right and so what
they did is they induced these feelings
in people so they actually had them do a
writing exercise where they thought
about the most anxiety-provoking thing
or the happiest thing and they and so
they really induced that feeling in
people and then they had them do a
problem-solving test a brainstorming
task where they had to come up with a
new solution think outside of the box
come up with as many ideas as they could
to a problem um i think it was uh they
said oh these teachers are trying to
teach students this new thing how would
you do it to be innovative
and then they measured they had induced
people to have each of these emotions
separately and then they measured how
many how much fluency there was meaning
how many ideas people came up with and
then how innovative and creative they
were and they had a coding scheme to
determine that and they found that
anxiety when you induced anxiety it made
people not only more fluent there were
more ideas but they were more out of the
box in their thinking and they persisted
more
they cared about what they were doing
and even when they hit some roadblocks
they just kept going and so they come up
came up with more ideas
there's also a great um
a concept that patrick godrow who's a
canadian psychologist came up with that
i think is also about the creativity
behind anxiety and it's a concept called
excellencism
so we know that perfectionism is toxic
it's punishing
it's like this this you know this
pursuit of flawlessness that always
fails and it lead you know and we know
that perfectionism real punishing
perfectionism is associated with more
anxiety clinical anxiety more depression
suicidality and actually worse
performance people who are
perfectionists
tend to perform less well because they
just don't know when to stop trying to
get it right they just don't know how to
use their time wisely in a lot of cases
so that's perfectionism excellencism is
sort of the light side of that darkness
so excellencism is knowing that you know
i can never be perfect but i can be
really good i can be excellent and i
believe i can be excellent and i'm okay
with failing in order to get there and
sometimes on my way to getting to
excellent i can just be good enough
and i'll get there and so excellentists
people who think about achievement that
way
they tend to be more anxious not
clinically anxious but just have a
heightened level of anxiety but they
also have more curiosity they're more
open to experience
and they tend to be more creative
and more productive
so here we have this anxiety fueling
this pursuit of excellence not
perfectionism but excellence actually
leading to more productivity and
creativity when you measure it and these
sort of you know divergent thinking
tasks and all sorts of other ways that
gadra and his colleagues have done
what about when you feel nerves or you
have that sort of anxious quasi-nervous
response and your ability to think
laterally just feels like it's being
completely shut down and like
my entire mind has gone blank here is
that something different is that not
anxiety that's totally anxiety so
your body you know as we talked about
with that that study was socially
anxious people in the and this giving a
public speech
you know so say you're about to come on
a podcast with someone you've never met
before and you have to go on this old
school like video conferencing thing
called skype and you're feeling a little
nervous you can't quite get it and the
butterflies in your stomach start right
so what do you do you say okay
first of all that's information that i
care about this interview you know i'm
not just falling asleep and like uh who
cares um this conversation is going to
be interesting and actually it really is
my body preparing to overcome whatever
obstacles i need to face and to persist
even when i can't get that damn video on
and it's like all talking um and and so
you interpret it that way and there
might be a few times as you're as you're
listening to what's being said or you
have ideas going through your head you
might draw a couple blanks but you know
especially if you're an excellencist you
know that well i can stumble a little
but i have other ideas that are great
and i'll be able to
because i've mastered this topic i'll be
able to come up with something else
interesting to say or i could ask uh the
person i'm talking to a couple questions
and that will so you just have this
curiosity and attitude of
it's okay failure's not failure is not
failure failure is not a malfunction you
know being anxious is not dangerous
it's part of being human it's part of
the messy act of being human and it just
changes everything as soon as you accept
that and really internalize that like
saying the word repression instead of
depression when you mean to
that might have been a friday and slip
on your part
i'm not nervous i'm excited yeah yeah i
really really like it uh tracy let's
bring this home where should people go
if they want to check out the stuff that
you do
drtracyphd.com
i love it the book will be linked in the
show notes below as well future tense i
really like this there are a number of
different science communicators that
seem to be converging on this similar
sort of reframing
slash
um you have control over your in a state
place and it's not woo
and it's based in science and i very
very much like it and i'm looking
forward to seeing what you do next thank
you so much what a pleasure to speak
with you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace